- Good morning believe nation,
today's message is fill a void.
Over to you, Dom Kennedy.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Fill a void, you know
Fill a void.
There's jobs out here,
figure out what, whatchu can make better.
That's better than any job.
Like you can go get a job doin something,
whatever you don't want to
but figure out where you can
really fit in and be happy.
And then worry about, the
money's going to come.
That's not going to be a problem,
cause if you fillin' a void
and you addin' to you know
whatever, you might be like you know what,
they don't have good food at Venues.
You know what I'm sayin'?
And you might just be the
person the next billionaire
to just have bomb food at concerts.
Like straight up though.
Straight up though.
Or just figure out a way to
involve like media in concerts.
Like where people could be
there and you could like,
you know whatever.
Some type of web, but just
figure out something that
people is not doing, know what I'm saying?
That you feel like people could utilize.
And do that.
- So a lot of the most successful
businesses that were ever
founded were by people
that were scratching their
own itch.
You see a problem,
you see something out
there that you don't like,
you want to solve it,
and so you go out and do it.
This is what makes
entrepreneurs successful.
This is what separates
us from everyone else.
Most people see a problem
and what do they do?
They complain.
Most people just complain.
They complain about the government,
they complain about the
transportation system
and they complain about all
the negative things that are
happening in their life.
And they advocate
responsibility by complaining.
Where entrepreneurs,
we're the ones who do something about it.
We're the ones who see
that negative and we turn
it into an opportunity for ourselves.
And so if you see yourself complaining,
see yourself wishing that
something else had been created
to solve this problem,
go out and solve the problem.
And then you can sell the
solution to other people.
So when I look at my
first software company,
it was a BioTech software company.
It was stared by two researchers who
were at a university,
and they wanted software
that could help them do their
experiments more simply.
To reduce the number of steps,
to improve the efficiency
and to create a more
visual product that people
could understand.
And nothing existed.
Everything was super
scientific and super technical,
and they didn't understand how to use it.
And so they built a better
version for themselves,
and they shared it.
And that was the genesis
of the first product.
If I look at this YouTube channel,
a lot of the videos that we end up doing
are requests.
It's like, what do you guys want to hear?
And my requests as well to create this.
I wanted to be surrounded
by successful people
on a daily basis.
That's the thesis of this channel.
I wanted to be surrounded by success
and use that to push me into
a more powerful direction
forward.
Nobody had done it the
way I wanted it done.
Nobody was profiling
the famous entrepreneurs
in the way that I needed.
And so I was consuming all
of these videos and content
and hours and hours and hours of footage,
to get little hits.
You know consume eight hours
of Elon Musk interviews
to get like five minutes of gold.
I wanted that process to be simpler.
I wanted to just turn on
YouTube and there's a video.
I click play, I get
inspired, I learn something,
and I wanted to be consistent.
I don't watch the same video 100 times
because the impact would wear out.
So this channel was designed for me,
and I'm happy to share it with you guys.
And we have this relationship
where it's for both of us
and that's amazing.
And so if you see a void in the market,
if you see a problem that exists,
that's quite often your
next best business idea.
That's where so many of the
best businesses have been built.
And where your next big
opportunity may be coming from.
So the question of the day today
is what is the void that you see
and are trying to fix
right now in the market?
Leave it down in the comments below,
super curious to find out.
I also wanted to give a quick
shout out to Gary Freeman.
Gary thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
your one word, really really
means a lot to me, Gary.
And I appreciate your
support and I hope you're
enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going.
- Steadman and I were in a hotel
watching some bad television.
And I was complaining about
the state of television,
talk shows in particular.
And he said "why don't you change it?"
Why don't you just get your own network?
and I thought that that
was a ridiculous idea.
And then he started to talk about it,
and he wrote some things down.
And I saw the word own and I thought
own, ow, oh that's my,
those are my initials.
And I said, wouldn't it be
something if I could create
a network, that was really about mindful,
and I underlined the
word mindful, television.
- [Interviewer] 15 years
later, those scribblings came
closer to a reality when
she was approached by
David Zaslav, the president
of the Discovery network.
- My view was, if we want to do this,
you have to be all in.
She paused,
and then she said to me
"yeah, it's meant to be."
And we shook hands, and
that's how our journey began.
- At first I thought
well great the network,
oh gee this is the dream I had.
And I actually showed him the
piece of paper where I had
written it down in segments.
And as that started to settle in with me,
I thought whoa
what is this I've gotten myself into?
This is a lot more work
than I ever imagined.
- [Interviewer] Are you scared?
- Very scared. I was very scared.
And I would wake up in
the middle of the night,
and I would literally
(gasps)
like clutching my chest,
like what have I done.
What have I done?
- [Interviewer] What if you fail?
- That's what I was afraid of.
That's what I was afraid of.
The reason why I made the
decision to go forward,
is because I believe that people deserve
to have value centered
inspirational programming
for themselves.
I believe that television
has become in many ways,
a null.
It has become (inaudible)
and not all of it,
but I think that I have
something to offer.
- [Interviewer] What
circumstances were present
that made this idea catch fire.
- Sure so I think there
were sort of two components.
And the first component is
probably that social media
was starting to feel a little stale.
There's only so many beautiful,
attractive, cool pictures
that you can take and
when you see all of them,
day after day after day, it
just kind of gets boring.
So I think there was that aspect of it.
And I think the other thing
is that we really identified
that this femoral thing
was core to conversation.
And so, if you wanted
to have a conversation,
one of the best parts about
it was that you were left with
the memory but not
necessarily a transcript.
And I think that that really
drove the great feeling that
you have when you share snaps
with friends and they're
silly and you know, not exactly perfect.
You know there was obviously
a place for all of these
great photos that you
wanted to save and keep.
And there wasn't so much a
place to have a conversation.
And I think you know, there's
a nice balance with both.
And so I think we sort of filled a void,
the conversation void that was missing.
- I just think music is changing
in terms of the gate keepers
and the power that be,
the powers that be.
And I feel like it's in
a more democratic time.
The power is in the musician's
hands and in the fan's hands.
I mean they choose what
matters, what's relevant,
what sells, what you know.
It's not so much
the old powers, the old
gate keepers who could just
shove something down your throat.
You see less and less
superstars and more and more
organically grown artists like myself,
just doing something a little
different, know what I mean.
Bending genres and don't
necessarily fit within this like
format or walls of you know, whatever.
Just kind of doing their
own thing and finding an
audience and growing
it organically and just
making it happen.